down the ages past Allah sent his
Messengers to deliver humankind from
Darkness to light invite all to the way
of thy Lord with wisdom and beautiful
preachings and argue with them in the
ways that are best and most
gracious that's also the ongoing mission
of Islamic Research Foundation or irf
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to
mankind founded in
1991 irf today offers some of the best
services and facilities in the world for
presenting an understanding of Islam in
an objective and scientific
way its programs are primarily focused
on correcting misconceptions and
promoting understanding of
Islam irf also imparts dawa training to
D to aptly convey The Message of
Islam irf has one of the most modern
Studios producing programs presenting
Islam which are beamed regularly on many
International TV channels in over 150
countries Dr Zakir Nik president of irf
reaching out across countries worldwide
from America to Europe to Africa to Asia
to Australia strives to clarify Islamic
viewpoints he dispels the many media
myths and anti-islamic prejudices
propagated the world over by
anti-islamic forces Dr Zakir Nik is a
medical doctor doctor he's acclaimed the
world over for his spontaneous and
convincing replies to questions posed by
critics and
Skeptics during the question and answer
sessions after his
talks he is also renowned for his
verbatim quotes with references from
major religious scriptures of the
world Dr zaker and other faculty of the
irf trained many dais in effective dawa
techniques
ir's website provides free dawa training
material for you to download and become
an effective dii
yourself Dr Zakir Nike's talks are
available on audio and video cassettes
CDs and DVDs the world
over irf today is creating a change in
the hearts and minds of millions of
Muslims and non-muslims worldwide
towards a proper understanding and
respect for Islam have a question or
doubt about Islam and its teachings now
you know one of the best Resource
Centers to get convincing answers from
is Islamic Research Foundation 5658
tandel Street North dri Mumbai
400009 India phone 2373
6875 fax 9122 2373 0689 email Islam at
the rate
of.net for more information log on to
our website www . IR
[Music]
[Applause]
f.net
bahman
We Begin the
program with the
recitation from the Holy
Quran by Kari rahan galib followed by
its English
translation by Brother Ashraf
muhammadi
[Music]
man
h
[Music]
ill
man
[Music]
ill
[Laughter]
[Music]
ill
Mal
[Laughter]
Al
is Al
[Music]
J
ill
[Music]
Subhan
you said
[Music]
all
the
translation from Surah isra chapter
17 verse
110 I seek Refuge with Allah from Satan
the accursed in the name of Allah most
gracious most
merciful say call upon Allah or call
upon
Rahman by whatever name you call upon
him it is well for to him belong the
most beautiful
names the
translation from Surah alash chapter
59: 22 to
24 Allah is he than whom there is no
other God who knows all all things both
secret and open he most gracious most
merciful Allah is he than whom there is
no other God The Sovereign the Holy One
the source of peace and
Perfection the guardian of Faith the
preserver of safety the exalted in might
the irresistible the Supreme glory to
Allah high is he above the partners the
attribute to him he is Allah the Creator
the evolver the bestower of forms or
colors to him belong the most beautiful
names whatever is in the heavens and on
Earth does declare his praises and glory
and he is the exalted in might the wise
verily
Allah has spoken the
truth now we
have the recitation from the holy
Vedas by Pandit nir
shastri Pandit chandrapal
shastri and pundit harom shastri all
three are from the Arya samaj
Mumbai
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
IND
[Music]
mag
o
[Music]
shant
sh
[Music]
shant
sh
[Music]
shant
oh
[Music]
shant thank you the translation by
Brother Ashraf
muhammadi
verses recited by the priests the
translation of two of these verses is in
front of
you the first set of shlokas were from
rig book one hymn 164 Mantra
46 it
reads God is one but the wise call him
by various names to denote note his
different
attributes they call
him Indra God of supreme power or Lord
of the world Mitra the friend of all
waruna the most desirable Supreme Being
AGI The all- Knowing supreme leader Diva
The Shining one and Gutman the mighty
Universal spirit
the rishes describe the one being in
various ways calling him Agni self
refulgent one Yama the ordainer of the
world and
mataran the life energy of the
universe the next
schlock was from
yajur chapter
40 verse
1 it says enveloped by by the Lord must
be this all each thing that moves on
Earth with that renounced enjoy yourself
coet not wealth of any
man thank
you dear brothers and
sisters assalamu
alayum may peace be on
you I Dr Muhammad n am your host and
coordinator for this evening's
program I welcome each one of
you to this momentous
event an event with a
difference the difference being
similarities similarities between
Hinduism and
Islam
is perhaps for the first time in the
history of Modern
India that we are
holding a talk of such vital
relevance a talk that attempts to bring
to Common
terms the followers of this great
Nations two major
religions Hinduism and Islam
an educative
talk that will try to dispel
misconceptions and promote understanding
about the common teachings of Hinduism
and
Islam my school
principal had once told
me the law of the Jungle is kill or be
killed
but the law of life is Live and Let
Live it's a
tragedy so many of us
choose to live by the law of the
Jungle we choose blind
hate over compassion and
understanding fallible
falsehood over transparent
truth it's
sad we cannot live
together amicably many a
times understand our
similarities learn to live with our
differences no wonder somebody once
remarked men will Wrangle for
religion fight for
it die for it
anything but live for
it
tonight like brothers in
humanity Let's Learn To Live and Let
Live
but this is Possible only if we
understand each other's
perspectives beliefs and
religions
surprisingly both Hinduism with its 850
million followers and
Islam with its 1,300 million
followers remain mysteries in the minds
of
many tonight we have before us the
internationally acclaimed orator on
comparative religion Dr Zakir
Nik Dr
zaker is a medical
doctor his critical
analysis and convincing
answers are founded on fact
since he quotes verbatim from various
religious scriptures like the noble
Quran
the Holy Bible and the ancient
Vedas in the last 7 years Dr Zakir has
delivered more than 700 public
speeches in various countries worldwide
including the USA Canada UK Saudi Arabia
UAE South
Africa
Australia Singapore Malaysia Hong Kong
and Guyana in South America in addition
to numerous public talks in
India he appears
regularly on many International TV
channels in over 150
countries this
evening he would be
highlighting the
similarities
between Hinduism and Islam before
us
may I present before you all brothers
and sisters in
humanity Dr Zakir
n
alhamdulillah
my respect
ERS and my dear brothers and sisters I
welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty
God be on all of
you the topic of this evening's talk is
similarities between Hinduism and
Islam I started my talk by quoting a
verse from the Glorious Quran from Surah
Al Iman chapter number three verse
number 64 which
says say oh people of the
book come to commment terms as between
us and you which is the first term
Allah that we worship none but one
almighty
God that we associate no partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and P other than
Allah if then they turn back
say that we are Muslims bowing our will
to Allah subhana wa
tala this verse though it specifically
refers to theab to the Jews and
Christians in general it can be used for
people of different faiths and according
to me it is the best
verse that can be used while speaking
with different kinds of people it
says come to Common terms as between us
and you which is the first
term that we worship none but one
almighty
God that we associate no partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and Pence other than one almighty
God it is not
appropriate to try and understand a
particular religion by trying to observe
the followers of that religion because
many of times the followers they
themselves are not aware about the
teaching of the religion therefore the
best and the most appropriate method of
trying to understand an religion is to
try to understand the authentic sources
of that religion the authentic
scriptures of that
religion if you have to understand
Hinduism you have to try and understand
the Sacred Scriptures of Hinduism the
most sacred are The
Vedas and the shlokas were recited from
these scriptures that is supplemented by
the upanishad by theas Raman maharat
bhagat
Gita by the puranas Manus Etc but the
most sacred are The Vedas amongst all
the Hindu scriptures so if you have to
understand Hinduism you have to try and
understand the Sacred Scriptures of
Hinduism similarly in Islam the most
sacred scripture is the Glorious Quran
which is the last and final
revelation of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of
almighty God which was revealed to the
last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him it is
supplemented with the authentic a Hadith
the seeings and the traditions of of
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him so if
you have to understand Islam you have to
try and understand the Glorious Quran
and the authentic Hadith of the
Prophet let's understand the definition
of the word
Hindu
is a geographical
definition which refers to the people
living beyond the rivers
Hindu or the people living in the land
watered by river
Indus according to
historians this word Hindu was first
used by the Persians when they came to
India through the Northwestern passes of
himalia it was also used by the
Arabs according to the Encyclopedia of
religion ethics it is mentioned in
volume number six reference number
690 that the word Hindu
is not found in any of the Indian
literatures or scriptures before the
Advent of the Muslims to
India and according to pundit javal Neu
who wrote the book discovery of India on
page number 74 and 75 he writes that the
earliest occurrence of this word Hindu
can be traced to a tantric of 8th
Century fee mean the first time the word
Hindu was used was was in the 8th
Century in the Christian era in at
tantri
scripture and it was used to
describe the people it was never used
for describing the followers of a
particular
religion its
relationship to religion is of late
occurrence the word Hinduism is derived
from the word Hindu and it was first
time used by the English Men by the
westerners by the britishers to describe
a group of beliefs and faiths of the
people of India according to the new
encyclopedia Banica volume number 20
reference number 581 it says that the
word Hinduism was first used by the
British writers in the year
1830 to describe the religion and the
belief of the people of
India since the word Hinduism was first
coined by the English man it's a English
word today the Hindu Scholars they
object and they say that Hinduism is a
misn NOA the right word for the religion
should be sanatan DH that is eternal
religion or Vic DM that is the religion
of The Vedas and according to Swami
vianda Hinduism is a Mis Noma the
followers should be called as vedantist
that means the followers of the Vas
so in short the word Hindu is a
geographical definition used for
describing the people of India its
relationship to religion is of late
occurrence the word Hinduism was first
used in
1830 by the British writers it's an
English
word and the word sanatan DH Vic DH and
vedantist is more appropriate but these
two are nowhere to be found in any
Indian scriptures all these words have
come into existence in the past two
centuries let's understand the
definition of the word
Islam Islam
comes from the word salm which means
peace it's also
derived from s which means to submit
your will to almighty
God Islam in short means peace obtained
by submitting your will to almighty God
and anyone who submits his will to
almighty God he is called as a
Muslim this word Islam occurs in various
places in the Quran as well as authentic
Hadith of prophet mam
including the word Islam
occurs in Surah Bak chapter number 2
verse number 2 and8 and the word Muslim
occurs in several places in the Quran
and theth including Surah Al Imran 3:64
there's a
misconception that Islam is a new
religion which came into existence 4
years back and Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he was the founder of this
religion of Islam in fact Islam is there
since time immemorial since man set foot
on this Earth and Prophet Muhammad PE be
upon Him is not the founder of this
religion but he is the last and final
messenger of almighty God to whom was
revealed the last and final message the
Glorious Quran 1400 years
back in this talk of mine today I will
not be speaking about those
similarities between Hinduism and Islam
which is commonly known by most of the
followers of both of these
religions I will not be
speaking about both the religions say
that you should speak the truth that you
should not tell a lie that it should not
be cruel that it should be kind that it
should not steal all these are known by
the followers of both this religion in
fact I will be speaking about those
similarities which are not known
commonly by both the followers of these
religions first we'll discuss the
similarities between
Hinduism and the pillars of Iman of
faith in
Islam Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Bak chapter number two verse number 177
Allah says that it is not righteousness
that you turn your face to the east or
west but it is righteousness that you
believe in Allah you believe in the last
day that you believe in his angels his
books and his
Messengers there's a Hadith which is
mentioned in s Muslim volume number one
in the book of IM chapter number two
Hadith number six a person approaches
the prophet and asks him what is Iman
and the prophet replies Iman is
believing in Allah in
God in his angels his books his meeting
his
Messengers in the resurrection that life
after death and in that is Destiny so
basically there are six pillars of IM in
Islam the first is believing in God
second is believing in his angels third
is believing in his books fourth is
believing in his Messengers fifth is
believing in Resurrection that is
Hereafter that is life after death and
sixth is believing inad that is
Destiny first we'll discuss what
Hinduism has to say about the first
pillar concept of
God if you ask a common Hindu that how
many gods does he believe in some may
say three some may say 10 some may say
100 some may say thousand While others
will say 33 cres 330 million but if you
ask this question to a learned Hindu
who's well versed with the scriptures he
will tell you that the Hindus should
actually believe and worship only one
almighty God but the common Hindu he
believes in a philosophy known as
pantheism
the common Hindu believes that
everything is God the tree is God the
sun is God the Moon is God the human
being is God the snake is God what we
Muslims believe that everything is God's
g o d with an apostrophe everything
belongs to God the tree belongs to God
the sun belongs to God the moon belongs
to God the human being belongs to God
the snake belongs to God so the major
difference between the Hindus and the
Muslims is the common Hindu says that
everything is God we Muslims say
everything is gods g o d with an
apostrophes the major difference is the
apostrophes if we can solve this
difference of apostrophe the Hindus and
the Muslims will be United how do we do
it as the Quran
says come to Common terms as us and you
which is the first
term that we believe in only one
almighty
God let us try and understand what the
Hindu scriptures have to say say about
almighty
God it is mentioned in the
chandad chapter number six section
number two verse number one it
says it's a Sanskrit quotation which
means god is only one without a second
it is mentioned in
thean chapter number six verse number
n
Jad of him there are no parents he has
got no Lords almighty God has got no
mother he has got no father he has got
no master he has got no
Superior it's mentioned in the
shashar chapter number four verse number
19 of him there is no
likeness it's further mentioned in the
Shish chapter number four verse number
20 that his form cannot be seen no one
can see him with the
eyes amongst all the Hindu scriptures
the most widely read and the most
popular is the bhagwad Gita it's
mentioned in bhagwad Gita chapter number
7 verse number 20 all those whose
intelligence has been stolen by material
desires they worship Dem Gods which
means all materialistic people they
worship Demi gods that is the false gods
besides the one true almighty God it's
further mentioned in bhagwad
Gita chapter number 10 verse number
three that he who knows me as The
Unborn the beginningless the Supreme
Lord of all the
worlds among the Hindu scriptures the
most sacred are the vas it's mentioned
in the
Y chapter number 32 verse number
of him there are no images almighty God
has got no images and further says that
he is unborn he alone should be
woried it's
mentioned chapter number
40 verse number 8 that almighty God is
imageless and pure it's mentioned in
chapter number 40 verse number
N means Darkness Shanti means entering
and asui means the natural things like
fire water
air it means they are entering Darkness
those who worship the natural things
like fire water air and the verse
continues they are entering more in
darkness those who worship the created
things like table chair Idol Etc who
says that yaj chapter number 40 verse
number
9 it's further mentioned in the
book number 20 himym number 58 verse
number three Mah verily great is
almighty God and amongst the Hindu
scriptures the most sacred are the
r it is mentioned in
r book number one hymn number
164 verse number 46 the shlokas which
were
recited by the respected pundits it says
viaa Vante which means truth is one God
is one sages call him by various names
and the same message repeated in r book
number 10 himym number 114 verse number
five that God is one but sages call him
by a variety of
names and in rig alone
in book number two himym number one
there are no less than 33 different
attributes given to almighty God many of
which were
recited by the respected
pundits one amongst them in rade book
number two him number one verse number
three is
brahama brahama is called the Creator if
you translate into
Arabic it means khik we Muslims have got
no objection if someone calls almighty
God as khik or the Creator but if
someone says the Creator is almighty God
who has got four heads and on each head
is a crown we Muslims take strong
exception to it moreover you're going
against chapter number four verse number
19 which
says of him there is no
likeness another attribute given in
rade book number two himm number one
verse number three is
Vishnu Vishnu is called the sustainer
the cherisher if you translate into
Arabic it is somewhat similar to R we
Muslims have got no objection if someone
says allmighty God is r or sustainer or
cherisher but if someone says sustainer
is almighty God who has got four hands
one of his right hand is the dis is the
chakra the other hand he has the Conch
he's traveling on the bird by the name
of guda or reclining on a couch of
snakes we Muslims take strong objection
to it moreover you're going against J
chapter number 32 verse number three
which
says of him there are no images if you
read R all these descriptions are not
given the attributes are given that
almighty God is Creator he sustainer his
cherisher we have no objection with
attribute but these images are not given
because it is mentioned in The Vedas
that almighty God has got no images
it's further mentioned
in book number eight himym number one
verse number
one means do not worship anyone except
the one God it's mentioned in
the book number six himym number 45
verse number
16 praise him alone the one true God and
the brah
Sutra of the vanta
isaham which
means there is only one God not a second
not at all not at all not in the least
bit so if we read the Hindu scriptures
we understand the concept of God in
Hinduism next try and understand the
concept of God in Islam the best reply
any Muslim can give you regarding the
concept of God in Islam is quote to
youas chapter number 112 verse number 1
to4 which
says say he is Allah one and only
Allah Allah the absolute and
eternal he begets not nor is
begotten and there is nothing like him
this is a forine definition of almighty
God given in the Glorious Quran in suras
which is the same as which was mentioned
in the Hindu scriptures the first
is say he is Allah one and only same as
the
CH chapter number six section number two
verse number one which
says God is only one without a
second the second
was Allah Allah the absolute Eternal
same as bhagat Gita chapter number 10
verse number three which says that he is
the Lord of all the
world verse number
three he begets not nor is begotten same
as chapter number six verse number n
which
says which means almighty God has got no
parents he has got no Lords he has got
no mother he has got no father and the
last
is there's nothing like him
same as mentioned in
the chapter number four verse number 19
as well as chapter number 32 verse
number three which
says of him there is no likeness he has
got no
images the definition of almighty God
given in Quran and the Hindu scripture
is exactly the
same this is the Touchstone of Theology
suras and what's quoted from the Hindu
scriptures is the Touchstone of
theology if anyone says that so and so
candidate is God you put him to the test
of surlas if that candidate passes the
test he is a true almighty God if he
doesn't he is not a true God for example
some people say that bhagan rashish he's
almighty God
there was Hindu brother of US during
question answer time once he said that
if we Hindus don't agree bhagan n is God
I know that I never said that Hindus say
bhagan Nish is God I said some people
say that bhagan Nish is God I've read
the Hindu scriptures nowhere do the
Hindu scriptures say that bhagan n is
God but there are many people who have
converted from different religions and
now they say that bhagwan djes is God
let us put bhagan djes to the test of
surlas and the test of the Hindu
scriptures
the first
is say Allah one only there's only one
God without a second is
rajnish one and only is he the only man
who has claimed Divinity there are many
who have claimed Divinity especially in
this country of us there are thousands
of men who have claimed Divinity he's
not the only
one but rajish B say no he's unique he's
the only one let's go to the next
test Allah Allah the absolute and
eternal was rajish absolute and eternal
we know from his
biography that he was suffering from
asema from diabetes from chronic back
ache imagine almighty God suffering from
astha from diabetes from chronic back
ache third test
is he begets not no he begotten same in
thean
chapter number six verse number
NASA of him there are no parents no
mother no father we know
rajnish had a father and mother he was
born in the state of madya Pradesh in
1981 he goes to America and takes
thousands of Americans for a ride and in
the state of Oregon he starts his town
known as
rajuram later on the American government
they arrest him and they put him behind
bars and he claims that the American
government gave me slow poisoning in the
jail imagine almighty God being slow
poisoned and later on in 1985 the
American government they kick him out of
the country he comes back to India and
in the city of Puna he restarts his
Center which is today known as the oso
commune and if you go to Puna and visit
the center of the oo commune it is
mentioned on his Tom Stone bhagan
rajnish o
rajnish never born never died but
visited the Earth from the 11th of
December 1931 to the 19th of January
1990 never born never died but visited
the Earth from the 11th of December 1931
to the 19th of January
1990 never born never
died they forgot to mention on this
Tombstone that he was not given visas to
21 different countries of the World
Imagine almighty God coming in this
world to visit the world and he requires
visas to visit different
countries and the Ark Bishop of Greece
said if you don't remove rajnish out of
this country we'll burn his house and
the house of his disciples and the last
test there's nothing like him is so
stringent that no one besides the true
almighty God can pass the moment you can
compare God to anyone
in this world in this universe he's not
God we know rajish you was a human being
like us had two eyes one nose two hands
two legs had a white
beard the moment you can compare God to
anything in this world he is not
God for example if someone says that
almighty God is a thousand times
stronger than Arnold swasher you might
have heard the name of Arnold swasher
the person got the title Mr Universe Mr
world the strongest man in the world the
strongest man in the
universe if someone says that almighty
God is thousand times stronger than an
swasher the moment you can compare God
to anyone whether it be annar whether it
be daras Singh or whether it be King
Kong whether it be a thousand times or
whether it be a million times the moment
you can compare God to anything in this
world he's not
God there's nothing like
him
my request is to my dear brothers and
sisters whichever God you're worshiping
put them to the test of surlas and the
test of the Hindu scriptures if they
pass the test they are true almighty God
if they fail they are
not otherwise Allah subh says in the
Quran in is chapter number 17 verse
number 110 the ayat which was recited by
the say call upon Him by Allah or by
rman by whichever name you call upon him
to him belongs the most beautiful name
you can call Allah subhana wa ta'ala by
any name but it should be a beautiful
name it should not K upal
picture and there are no less than 99
different attributes given to almighty
God in the Glorious Quran Alman
Alim Alim most gracious most merciful
most wise no less than 99 and the
crowning one is Allah why do we Muslims
prefer calling Allah by the Arabic word
Allah instead of the English word God
because a person cannot play Mischief
with the Arabic word Allah as you can do
with the English word God for example if
you add as to God it becomes Gods that's
plural of God there nothing like plural
Allah say is Allah one and only if you
add d e s says to God it becomes goddess
meaning a female god there's nothing
like male Allah or female Allah Allah
has got no gender he's unique if you add
father to God it becomes Godfather he's
my godfather he's my guardian there's
nothing like Allah father or Allah B
Islam if you add mother to God it
becomes god mother there's nothing like
Allah am or Allah mother in Islam Allah
is a unique word if you add 10 before
God it becomes 10 God meaning fake God
there's nothing like Allah and Islam
that's the reason we Muslims we prefer
calling Allah by the Arabic word Allah
instead of the English word God
but if there are some
Muslims who why speaking with the
non-muslims about Allah subhana wa
ta'ala these non-muslims may not know
the concept of Allah so if they use the
word God in of Allah like how I'm doing
today there's no problem but I'd like to
remind that God is not the appropriate
translation of the Arabic word
Allah and this word Allah is mentioned
in all the Sacred Scriptures of the
major world religion including
Hinduism it's mentioned in r book number
two himym number one verse number
11 is referred
as or Allah meaning
God Allah subhana wa ta'ala has also
mentioned by name in r book number three
him number 30 verse number 10 as well as
rig book number n hymn number 67 verse
number 30 he has been mentioned by name
as Allah in several verses of The
Vedas let's try and
understand the second pillar of
Iman that is
dangers as far as Hinduism is concerned
there's no particular concept of Angels
in Hinduism but Hinduism they have
certain super human beings which do work
which a normal human being can't
do in Islam angels are created by Allah
subhana wa tala almighty God and they're
created from
light they do not have a free will of
their own they obey all the Commandments
of Allah subhana wa taala and they have
been appointed certain duties for
example Archangel Gabriel he has been
appointed to get the Revelations from
Allah subhana wa ta'ala to The
Messengers of almighty
god let's discuss the third pillar of
Iman that is the
books first we'll discuss the books in
Hinduism the books in Hinduism are
divided into two broad categories the
shuis and the
smis the shuti means something which is
revealed
which is heard which is perceived which
is
understood the
shuis by the Hindu Scholars they're
considered to be of divine origin to be
the word of
God and they are the most Superior they
divided into The
Vedas and the
upanishads the word Veda is derived from
Sanskrit word vid which means knowledge
so vas means knowledge par
exellence these are the holy Vedas the
most secret and there are principally
four
vas we have the rig which deals with the
songs of
Praises we have the which deals with the
sacrific
formulas we have the Sam
W which deals with Melody
and
the which deals with magical
formulas vas are the most authentic and
the most sacred among the Hindu
scriptures
and these Vedas the exact
date when they were written or when they
were revealed is not known according to
Swami Dan sarasti of Arya Sam he says
that the V are
1,310 million years
old but according to the majority of the
scholars they say that The Vedas are
approximately 4,000 years old the exact
date is not known to whom it was
revealed or who compiled it is not known
where it came into existence the first
time in the world it's not known but yet
the vas are considered to be of